[Music]
when I first heard the idea for Rex and
I and and I hadn't seen anything but
they said well it's lost yeah it's the
show lost but done as a comedy I was
perplexed I was like I don't know how
that works then I started watching clips
from the show and I was oh this is
really funny I understand very much so
see you guys you pulled it off I mean
thank you that's amazing that we did you
know our pilot opens with a plane crash
sorry to spoil it and yet it's still
pretty funny yeah we haven't we're
really funny when we're like on the
brink of death yeah you crash and just
like on the show lost you crash on an
island and start to happen and but
there's a lot of very funny comedy good
physical comedy it looks like you're all
having a good time we're having a blast
it was it was so much fun to shoot and
you know it was I've only been able to
do a few things in my life and two of
the projects I've been in have had to
deal with the airplanes because we we
crashed an airplane in wrecked and in
the wolf of wallstreet we had a
different airplane scene where we shot a
60 person orgy on an airplane a little
bit different but still pretty amazing
things suddenly it's suddenly coming
back to me I remember this now you guys
are all of course its Wall Street XS
they're all on an airplane and together
a private plane and man that's an
intense it was I and I'll say it was it
sounds like it's every 12 year old boys
dream and it is I mean it's obviously
that man's dream but but in reality it
was it got gross real fast because we
had 60 naked bodies in a tiny metal tube
with a ton of hot lights like it it
turned into like a middle school locker
room in two minutes okay smelled so bad
yeah that when they yo cut it was like
how do I get out of here how do I place
it so so your teenage fantasy of I was
in a giant orgy and what was your
specific what like orgy scene what were
you doing I mean I remember just a lot
of naked bodies I don't remember what
your character was doing uh hi mom I'm
about
describe what I did in an orgy I was in
a seat with my tighty whities around my
ankles and a woman sitting on top of me
facing this way while I the turbulence
was making me vomit so really it's about
it's about 2 seconds so you see me like
the camera is just like oh here's Brian
he's about to vomit and now we're moving
up okay I was really fun I mean but we
shot a lot of stuff on the plane we also
shot a moment where a woman had to end
up for lack of a better term Moke
motorboat me
I think Andy will explain and I'm dating
yeah well she her chest was in my face
and and I would think you would be
motorboating I work well but but the the
difference that's why I didn't involve
does he take it yeah yeah very seriously
I have a very particular area of law
that I am an expert in okay and it's
it's all titty law okay well to be clear
I wasn't the one actually doing the face
movement oh I was moving I understand
you're lying there it's called
jump-starting him yeah exactly so she's
doing her body like this and these are
these large breasts um they were they
were at a quit size I'm not going to
guess the origin of them but let's say
they were they were as firm as two fists
that were just punching me in the face
over and over again so you it was not a
sensual experience for you you were
literally being beaten in the face
literally by this woman's elating brass
yeah like she could knock up Mike Tyson
with her chest
I did I had to say like Caesar can I get
an advil and an ice pack because it it
was there's a lot of you actually went
home that night after a day of having a
woman a strange woman's breasts yep
onion your face and you said I had a
terrible day at work today was an awful
experience I mean pity me well let's put
it this way I had only been married for
about three weeks so when I called my
wife yes that's what I said I was like I
just had the worst day I've ever had in
my life on set please understand that
that's why I'm telling this story right
here because I'm still paying penance
for what I did back then right
you